alright it looks like we're now live and
another doctor Sandler's philosophy
pop-ups for those who aren't familiar
with the concept it's sort of like a
restaurant pop-up it's not a permanent
location and I'm going to be doing some
discussion of a topic people have
already got some questions for me over
there but first I'm going to just
mention what what the topic for today is
and I thought it'd be kind of apt to
talk about you know continuing education
in the time of co vid 19 I think many of
you are well aware if you have any kids
in you know K through 12 or in college
or university and know that that
education has had to go online and that
has in some respects been you know quite
good and there have been a lot of cases
where things have not gone quite so well
and there's a lot of people giving
advice and I thought I would tell you a
little bit about my experience with with
what's going on and some of my insights
I've been teaching online for 8 years
and I've worked in nearly every one of
them you know the major online platforms
from blackboard all the way to you know
Moodle and canvas and everything in
between and I also help some people you
know convert things to online so and
I've been watching a lot of the
discourses you know educators suggesting
what we ought to do as a matter of fact
there was one that that drew a lot of
fire today where some some I think a
graduate student was writing about how
we all need to be dressed very nicely
for our classes so that we're presenting
the most professional image possible for
our students and boy did she get ratioed
with that and rightly so because it
shows the lack of priorities on you know
her part in the argument she was making
but so I'm going to talk a little bit
about all of that and I'll start
answering questions I'm gonna give
priority to those questions that
actually have something to do with topic
and then then I'll do other
questions as well so there's we're now
in week four I think of the great branch
line many of the schools that I'm
working that here in Wisconsin or that I
had connections with were already either
heading into spring break or are just
coming off a spring break when we
started doing our shelter-in-place
orders and had to convert to to online
so they quite often many of them
extended in extra week adding adding
another week to the spring break and
then the idea was educators should
figure out how to adapt their classes to
an online format and I think one of the
things that people got mixed up about
from the very start was the notion that
there is one single online format which
is complete nonsense there's a lot of
ways to teach online there isn't just
one single legitimate way really the
most important thing is thinking about
the needs of your students the learners
right not what suits you the best
not what would be most convenient for
the professor or the teacher or the
instructor but what students need and so
you know for me it's a no brainer you
shoot lecture videos you know that's one
of the best ways to do things a lot and
I created a lecture video specifically
to help first-time video creators to be
able to do that it's called the bare
bones of video production and it drew
you know some some discussion from from
some of my peers and it was done to help
them out there there was a lot of
back-and-forth discussion about whether
we should be trying to hold online class
sessions I think many of you know about
the the you know race to zoom although
you know if your school has Google
you've got Google suite and you just use
Google meat instead of zoom and if you
have if you're a Microsoft campus you
use whatever Microsoft's thing is I
forget exactly what it's called but
there were a lot of people who are like
oh we've got to do zoom you know and and
I'm hearing everything from instructors
saying we can't make students
Wein it's it's too much pressure on them
at one extreme all the way over to the
let's do our class sessions totally
online using zoom I will you know
lecture for for two and a half hours
straight and you know the right place to
be is kind of in the middle and so
there's been a lot of back-and-forth and
I've been involved in quite a few
discussions about how to do this best
and at the same time let me tell you
another sort of like inside thing we
instructors have just been deluged by
emails coming from two sources one is
all of the the big publishing companies
like Oxford and and you know
prentice-hall and all that trying to
shoot you know shoot out all these
solutions for us about how to do online
education they like vultures they were
ready to swoop in and you know offer us
solutions and stuff like that then
probably none of us can afford and which
would probably not be good for our
students then we had all of these
administrators and some would be good
you know teachers like constantly
shooting us emails about how we ought to
be contacting our students and don't let
any of them slip through the cracks but
also don't put any pressure on them and
we're gonna do this we're gonna do that
and we don't really have any news yet
but we're gonna have news later and just
back and forth and back and forth like
every single day now I'm teaching for
three different institutions Milwaukee
Institute of Art Design Milwaukee Area
Technical College and Carthage College
so I was getting all of this but I also
knew that was gonna be happening so I've
been around block for a while and I was
thinking to myself man if I was like a
first year teacher this would be a lot
to have on my plate and I also you know
I could also see like which schools were
doing better and handling it which
schools were doing not such a great job
and a lot of that depends on the
institutional culture and the leadership
so there's a lot of ways to do online
education well I've been like I said
I've been teaching online for eight
years and I've you know gone through a
lot of certifications and offered
workshops and how did you
my and also a video production so for me
this was not that big of a transition I
I already had three of my five classes
online before we went into this and I'd
then just transitioned the other two and
what I've been doing is is I offer
meetings for my students once a week
during their normal class time not for
like two and a half hours at a clip an
hour and a half at the most because
that's that's the limit of I would say
the online endurance and you know we
come in first we check in with the
students and see how they're doing and
you know we try to build up some rapport
then we get into the content and I don't
require the students to come to them you
know if they don't if there's something
going on you know they don't have to I
record the the session so that they can
then go in and I ask their fellow
students to think about questions that
maybe not just they would like to ask
but where their fellow students might
get mixed up and so my classes have been
going okay we I've lost a few students
there's gonna be some attrition but I've
managed to retain most of them and that
is the goal to get them through the
semester and through this crisis that
we're all we're all facing so alright
let's say we had a lot of a lot of good
questions here I'm gonna take retro
gamers can a joking thing at first
keeping items you bought by mischance
should be trashed in my opinion because
they might take on demonic property over
time no amount of stoic repose can
combat an inner demon we need to try
well I haven't ordered anything by by
mischance so I'm good that way I suppose
that could be good advice for somebody
else all right let's take Nicholas's
question here about graduate school so
this could be brought into by the way
how do you think kovat 19 will impact
graduate school admissions for 2021 I
plan on applying this fall but I'm not
sure I will be able to take the GRE
anytime soon so for those who don't know
the context of that the GRE is the
Graduate Record examination and it's
used for a lot of admissions here in the
United States I don't know if it gets
used overseas much but it's really it's
it's quite important here and so it's
similar to like you know if you're going
to go to law school you gotta take the L
that you're gonna go to med school the
MCATs there's other things it's other
similar tests and so generally people
prepare for these in advance and these
determine not the entire picture but
they determine a good part of the
picture of who gets admitted into
programs and you're right there's gonna
be some problems getting testing set up
now if you're trying to enter in 2021
you're gonna be sending out your
applications probably in the you know
late fall to winter of 2020 and then
hopefully hearing back right so right
now let's say things proceed along the
way projections are going we should
probably be back to doing things face to
face in some respects by the fall in
which case you'd you know you should be
able to take your gr EES they may find
some other ways to do it I mean
Educational Testing Service has a huge
stake and making sure that people take
their tests and that institutions use
the tests so they're they're probably
gonna find a solution right it may not
be a solution that we all love and think
is great but they'll find some way to do
it the other things that could be you
know issues that you you want to start
getting working on you know if you're
applying to grad school for starting in
fall 2021 it's never too early to start
thinking about letters of recommendation
and who you're gonna get to write those
you know and the other things that
you're gonna need in your your packet to
apply so but let's let's that scenarios
right well if we enough to be in
quarantine special lockdown / state home
well into the fall some schools are you
know currently looking at contingency
plans for having all the fall classes be
online here in Milwaukee because of the
DEM
kradic National Convention we already
got some schools that have had to change
their start dates for the fall because
the DNC moving into August being here
just actually blocks from from where I
live means that anything in the downtown
area so you know Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design Milwaukee School of
Engineering Marquette University most
likely even UW Milwaukee which is up
further north is probably going to be
affected and there they're moving for
that why because the students have to be
able to move in and when the DNC is here
they're shutting down all these streets
this is my connection is unstable let's
see what's going on here
well let's see it here we go so do our
connection was unstable for a moment the
Internet's of course are being heavily
taxed by everybody being on the internet
all at once so that can sometimes be an
issue all right let's see if we have any
other education questions to do to do ah
here's one from Jacob Z how do you see
the discussion base classrooms of
philosophy functioning in a digital
space it's hard for me to picture
students often going beyond their 500
word discussion posts well I mean we've
been doing it for years and years some
students do quite well in the online
setting and others struggle quite a bit
you know you you can meet by
videoconferencing I've been doing that
with my online classes for years
and you know both the ones that I do
academically and the ones that I've
offered through reason I owe and that
works just fine you can also do sort of
a hybrid where people write things and
then you know like you respond to them
in a video and you do so in a slower
tempo there's there's all sorts of
possibilities for for engaging in that I
will say this online learners have to be
a bit more self-directed than just you
know people
plot their butts in a seat in the
classroom and show up and you know do
the normal thing so that that's kind of
kind of important um let's see if we've
got any other questions here all right
so we don't have any education ones I'm
going to skip back up to the top nomina
is the problem of universals a relevant
question in philosophy today or is it
relegated to past concern totally
depends on who you ask right there's no
consensus in the field of philosophy
really about anything and anybody who
tries to tell you that they have like
the the Finn ative thing about what the
important problems are and what you know
what's been relegated to the past
they're either full of crap or ignorant
or trying to pass something off on you
you know they're there's the field of
philosophy is incredibly vast there's a
lot of people working in the field
teaching in the field the problem of
universals has not gone away even if
you're like doing you know cutting-edge
contemporary animal you know analytic
philosophy or continental philosophy
it's still there you know it's just
being done in different ways nominalism
maybe not necessarily in its its you
know classic sense but there's you know
there's different projects out there I
mean think about the the fascination
people have with with the lose and the
rhizome and all that sort of stuff and
what what's going on in that well you
know the lose is dealing with the
problem of universals and so is somebody
like Foucault and so is somebody like
Dario and you know we could go down the
list and you know it it's not as if
philosophical issues go away what what
we do often see is that sometimes they
get reappropriation more supernes
more and more superficial ways that
don't go back to earlier texts or do a
lot of reinventing the wheel but you
know now is nominalism a coherent
position that depends on who's
nominalism you're talking about it's not
it's not as if there's a big you know
association out there
of the nominalist there's a number of
different ways of being anomalous than
one can be more or less so and I think
you can say that about a lot of the isms
in philosophy they're not usually unif
achill terms as a matter of fact I'm
going to riffle off on this a little bit
got into a discussion with a colleague
about existentialism and you know
whether it was compatible with stoicism
and he was saying well the
existentialist and he was using Sargeant
as an example I was like hey I mean
Sartre is only one out of many of the
existentialist and a lot of them you
know differ from him in important ways
then he was like well I mean some of the
people didn't call themselves
existentialist because the term gets
used later on and then you know some of
them abandoned the term and I was like
who gives a [ __ ] you know what matters
is is what we have associated into this
big big Club that we call existential
ISM and you know all these different
media Dostoevsky chef stuff
Rilke you know all the way to - you know
these French thinkers and and you know
they are quite a varied Bunch you can't
just take sart's word as well.i I've
defined existentialism and
existentialism as a humanism that would
start sort of like trying to take over
the field and not everybody they are
bought into it right and and rightly so
and so it's the same way with nominalism
or other things we can say that there's
certain like traits or we can say
there's a historical continuity but we
can't we can't effectively generalize
about all of them out at once or Andrew
could you recommend and do you read
philosophical fiction works yeah I mean
I love Phil ok dick right I'm a big
[ __ ] as they used to call people
back then somebody who I get added to
recently who I like quite a lot and I'm
hoping to eventually do some stuff on
him our Scott backer and his second
apocalypse series very philosophical
another another thing I did in the
worlds of speculative fiction China
Mieville
really cool stuff there you know and
then we could talk about all sorts of
authors who were themselves
Lassa furs and wrote fiction like Iris
Murdoch you know so you know there's
there's a lot of things out there some
of it would fit into what we you know
consider political theory I was just
talking with a client about his
rereading of 1984 and we're you know
discussing the characters in it that's a
philosophical work of fiction right so
is a brave new world which we both
agreed is interesting and its ideas but
not so good in the writing and
characters you know the Picture of
Dorian Gray is another prime example
there's all sorts of philosophical
fiction Ursula K McQueen it would be
another speculative fiction author of
the 20th and when she lived into the
21st century who really wrote a lot of
great you know philosophically oriented
fiction and think about the left hand of
darkness and the lathe of heaven and
some of these some of these other
discussions and then we have authors
like Dostoevsky who the characters are
talking philosophy with each other so I
think you know that kind of fits in
there as well let's see cancer I hope
you're doing well thank you for all the
content you're very welcome Steve to
work good day no Bandito mass today I
don't wear a mask inside because I'm
inside Lennie penny I really like
Nietzsche
are there any philosophers you can
recommend that are like Nietzsche
depends on the like part right I mean
some other people in the existentialist
spectrum that are well worth reading
neat Nietzsche by the way read
Dostoevsky at the recommendation of
Georg Brandes the German critic and he
said oh this this guy's doing similar
stuff one of the reasons why we lumped
them together right so you know
Dostoevsky is well worth reading in that
sense chest off was one of the chests
off the great Russian who you know
becoming a emigres living in Paris
author was one of the first people to
recognize the affinities between
Dostoevsky and meetcha in a book
actually about the two so he would kind
of fit in you know Miguel de Unamuno
great Spanish author
let's say you know there's even
similarities between you know Nietzsche
and some things and William James on
some things too so those would be some
people Trenton says my content helped
him to read the categories that's good
Logan says which book should I read on
hoopla no idea you know
Elias your series on Heidegger was very
helpful you made reading being in time
bearable well I only covered a little
bit of it so I only made that little bit
bearable there's an awful lot more to
being in time that that we would need to
do John Ortiz why is philosophy so hard
to read because it's difficult you know
it's complex realities complex thinking
about the reality is going to be complex
it's just the nature of the game and as
a matter of fact in any field you start
going to the higher levels of it it gets
hard to read you know all right let's
see here Lyndon asks is this an AMA well
no it's a philosophy pop up which
usually turns into an AMA after a while
I have a idea in mind that I want to
talk about and then some people ask me
questions about that and other people
ask questions about other things if so
which psychological thinkers do you like
in terms of philosophy well you know I
find some people who originate within
the Freudian tradition quite interesting
i I think there's you know I don't just
submit this right line and Charles
Winnicott they all have goods that good
things to to put forward and this is use
sometimes you got to wade through some
some things that you're you know get a
look at his nonsense to do so and by the
way to two important British
philosophers who although actually let's
just call the one a British philosopher
I know the other one it might take some
umbrage at it who really engaged with
with the Freudian tradition would be
John wisdom and Alastair MacIntyre asked
me I wrote a book called the unconscious
in which he it was actually a course he
was teach thing
I generated a book out of it and he
looks at what parts of Freud II thinks
are nonsense and and not nonsense in the
sense of they don't make any sense just
soar like you know this is really
imaginative speculative stuff that
doesn't have any any real gripa gin in
life and then which parts you know we're
onto something I'm not a big fan of
young in part because most most of the
young'uns I meet they all just want to
talk about archetypes and shadows and
this and that and it's a very culty sort
of thing and and I do like reading young
but I like reading young less when he's
discussing his own stuff and more when
he's talking about other people and you
know I think that the cognitive
approaches in psychology have made some
important contributions sometimes
they're doing a lot of reinventing of
the wheel particularly the further that
we get into the CBT literature but you
know it's interesting and and I you know
like like some of the other people as
well some of the existentialist
psychologists and but I you know I can't
claim to done like a survey reading of
the field so all right um a can how do
you explain the value of continental
style philosophy to non philosophy
student you know there's cutting
themselves off from stuff and I don't
try to generalize about continental
philosophy because it's such a mixed bag
you know somebody like Derrida is very
very different than somebody like
Horkheimer is very different than either
of them from Hegel or you know from the
lose or any of those people it's it's a
the the notion that it's philosophy plus
poetry is is kind of its dismissive and
it's you know it's it's based in wanting
to not have to read this stuff and not
struggle with it I mean that said a lot
of times when you REBOUND at the the
language of things and making puns and
covering your your Basie's I mean the
really good stuff I mean think about it
like Nietzsche for example right or
Heidegger or mock shayla or you know
somebody else who does belong in that
Canon but often gets overlooked
Gabrielle Marcel
there's some some understanding that
philosophy is not just this narrow tiny
discipline that we fit into the stem
stuff which stem people don't even
understand what they're doing half the
time anyway in any sort of meta level
they they just apply their what they
learned and plow away with it
you know good continental philosophy is
drawing on a whole bunch of disciplines
linguistics
you know semiotic s-- sociology
psychology anthropology it's you know it
takes a lot to read it and if somebody
doesn't want to read it ask room you
don't have to make a case to them about
why they need to be studying that
sometimes people aren't mature enough to
to get into philosophical works and I'll
say this too about you know analytic
philosophy there's a lot of great
analytic philosophers out there they're
now you know all that well represented
in what gets studied today but I
mentioned John wisdom you know really
brilliant thinker well worth reading
you know Ellis Ambrose McIntyre started
out as an analytic philosopher he
eventually realized he had to get back
into you know something that's more
tradition guided that was neither
continental nor analytic but you know
that's that's where he started so you
know there's some good stuff there too
all right Steve to work does the digital
aspects virtual presence and key Plato's
forms and other philosophical contexts
concepts doesn't have plato's forms in
any way because all of that would just
be the same old stuff you know just
material instantiations of copies of
copies of copies but it could for other
philosophical concepts you know and you
know one of the interests there's an
interesting discussion in the stoic on X
2019 presentations which you can you can
find if you like go to my my channel
look at the stoicism playlist by Dan
Hayes the guy had you my you know radio
show with and he was talking about using
virtual reality to help like train
people
in how to apply stoic practices tease
that out but yeah there's there's
something good Lyndon ants did I ever
read friedrich jamison if so did i find
him interesting or buy into what are you
saying at all i've read him and i do
find him interesting i think that he's
unduly wordy and complex but he often
gets at the heart of things for those of
you don't know jamison is a continental
theorist who writes about a whole whole
range of things you know a lot of
contemporary Marxism stuff he's by the
way the people who want to know what
post-modernism actually means and not
just use the word you know is that like
a slur word or something like that you
want to read his post-modernism book you
know post-modernism the cultural logic
of late capitalism which is quite good
that said I think most jameson books
could probably be trimmed by about half
and he is he is very much a East Coast
intellectual you know coming from a
certain milieu you know you can learn a
lot by reading him I I've enjoyed
reading him in the past I think my level
of enjoyment has gone down and actually
this is kind of a good this is gonna be
a little bit of a riff going off so like
when I reread Nietzsche or I reread
Maurice blown-down or I reread Mary
Wollstonecraft it's it's not like I read
it and then I'm like I'm not getting out
of it what I used to get out of it sort
of like how people you know they take a
little bit of a drug and they get real
you know hi and enjoy it and then they
need a little they need more and more
because the same amount doesn't do it
for you right it doesn't work that way
like when when I read Plato every time
that I read Plato it's still getting
better and better and better actually
the same thing for Aristotle quite
frankly what's the exception of a few
works yeah it's good to have this
refresher it's not doing something for
me again so I don't know maybe maybe
Jamison
he's doing something useful but he's not
a great compelling author so yeah
alright um skip skip joven fluffin I've
been diving into rain and objectivism
lately some things I appreciate
something I do not and that's good yeah
I mean there's there's plenty of stuff
and Rand that is quite interesting and
sometimes on point you know for example
she discusses that need to have a
hierarchy of values the thing is that
almost anything interesting in Rand you
can get out of somebody else you don't
need to get it from Rand and then you
don't have to have all the commitments
to the the other extra stuff that you
know objectivism typically entails I'll
mention to that because I know people
who are Objectivists they're not all on
the same page there's four major
different organizations of Randee ins
here in the United States and they don't
get along with each other you know and
then there's like sort of free agents
out there and I know this because I've
got some friends who've circulated in
these these circles so you know alright
let's just skipped a little bit let's
see if we get if I can get back to this
did you do here we go
Thomas yes what's my view on Jordan
Peterson and I read 12 rules of life no
because I'm not gonna buy the book
because you know I and I think that he's
you know he's largely become sort of a
victim of his own success and again he's
sort of like Randy anything that's worth
fighting in Peterson you can find
somewhere else why why you know it's
people are attracted to a sort of
mystique and they were attracted to
having a daddy who could tell them what
to do I think and and give them some
some certainty but that's you know
that's not that's not important from a
philosophical perspective it often
stands in the way of actual development
so alright Lyle scribbles what are Matt
called the duel lists and it's got Peter
Carradine I always get
David mixed up and Harvey Keitel's the
main people in it it was done in the 70s
it's this back-and-forth fight between
these two Napoleonic officers and it has
just beautiful gorgeous backgrounds and
music and it's a great it's a really
well done movie and I really like that
and I'll mention to another marquee from
that time that I really enjoyed it was
actually two movies but it was shot as
one movie so they'd only pay two people
for one movie the three and the four
musketeers but the one that was done in
the 70s the best one ever
the one that was done in the 90s pure
garbage you know hadn't had a lot of
star power but the other one did - the
one that was done in the 70s very well
researched very well done I like that
sort of stuff you know I like you know I
like quite a range of movies have I ever
thought about doing philosophical
reviews I've thought about it but it's a
matter of finding the time you know I'm
that's the the toughest thing for me to
get a hold of is is time to do things
and then I have to have the energy to do
it alright James here's a deep question
what is my thought on the PhD system
should there be any better easier ways
to get into university teaching
positions I think there's some utility
in in earning a PhD because here's
what's here's what's involved in doing a
PhD first you need to get a masters
unless you'd like jumping straight into
the ph.d program which I never advise
and the reasons I don't advise it is
because you're skipping stuff along the
way that should be part of your
formation so doing a master's is thirty
hours of coursework six of which would
be your master's thesis write a research
project that you carry out and it's
important to learn how to do research
effectively and how to explain and
defend your research so you do that at
the Masters used to be in the old days
we had comprehensive examinations at the
Masters levels as well we're like you to
know the history of philosophy a lot of
those have gone by the wayside it's too
bad there's a whole conversation
should be at their the PhD you do
another 30 hours of coursework graduate
coursework right and late in French
because because I'd learned French and I
you know I could come in and just
translate but you can also take classes
or stuff like that
I actually qualified with three research
languages in the course of my studies
but at the PhD level you do another
research language and you do 30 hours of
coursework like I said taking classes
and then you write a dissertation which
isn't just like you sitting down in a
room and writing it you research a
dissertation and before you research it
you do a prospectus and you have to
defend your prospectus and people give
you advice and suggestions and you also
back in our day we had to take four
different preliminary examinations
before we got to defend the prospectus
that's all important stuff doing all
that made me ready to teach in ways that
other people were not I mean I I got
thrown into teaching classes in in this
prison program I to teach the entire
curriculum and I could because I had a
really good graduate formation now the
problem is less on the formation part
although there's it's problematic in a
lot of places like if they if they teach
you the only thing that's going on is
continental philosophy the only thing
that's going on is analytic philosophy
they're doing bad formation for you III
think we ought to go to places that are
pluralist like where I went
you know Southern Illinois University
the problem is that there aren't that
many jobs and many of them aren't paying
well uh you know I actually interviewed
for a visiting assistant professor
position here locally a couple years ago
I was invited to apply for it I thought
why not you know and then when we got to
the interview I was shocked and amazed
to find out how little they were willing
to pay their incoming professors oh I
won't say what it was I will say that
they wanted to pay about half of what I
expected and they wanted to pay here's
out of graduate school so you know
there's a big there's a big
problem on the the finding positions and
for for these things and that's not
gonna change anytime soon because
schools have switched to using adjuncts
and trimming their staff and they spent
when they had money they spent it on
administrators and building buildings
that's where the majority of it went to
and the money's gone now you know it's
not gonna change anytime soon so it's
unfortunate
all right bozo online education it's
fine but it cannot be a complete
replacement for a real classroom take
lab exercises yeah yeah sure lab
exercises it's perfectly fine for doing
philosophy you know I mean again I've
been doing it for eight years fully
online and before that it was easy for
me to transition because I was already
using the course management systems to
keep my students in the online course
thing even for face-to-face classes
outside of class for hours at a time you
know so alright um Neel any educational
philosophy texts you'd recommend no
because I don't really specialize in
philosophy of Education alright did you
do the spoke films what sort of
responsibilities to intellectuals have
in dealing with laymen if Socrates like
as a Socrates like person in a real
world situation really an ethical
individual they're like Socrates they
are but like Socrates in what way it's
not like there's just one Socrates if
you mean somebody and then you know the
Stoics took other things from him so
there's there's a lot of different
Socrates out there all right van Piercy
what do I think about philosophers like
ray brassy or Robert random
I don't know brass ears but I knew I
dunno Brandon I like Brandon and Brandon
is a good example of an analyst various
philosophers particularly Hegel I think
is quite good so Nicholas he'll have I
met Steven Adler from uw-madison most of
his work revolves around 17th century I
don't think so
I only know a few people out at UW
Madison Madison is about 90 minutes from
here and I haven't I haven't actually
been to Madison since Wow I don't know
it's been a long long time there's no
reason for me to be out there almost
somebody invites me in but yeah all
right um
let's see here Neil bead is Plato
qualify as fictional philosophy you know
I guess you could say he's he's doing
the first right I mean that's what
Nietzsche thinks in the birth of tragedy
he says that Plato cobbles together a
new genre out of the shipwreck of
ancient Greek tragedy and was then the
new Socratic impulse so I guess you
could say he's doing that Damon Forbes
can the ID be thought of as the
irreducible like Leibniz monad the ID
making on what you're referring to their
identity of something right I have to
pass on that one
Jake could you elaborate on why fine to
lose his solo work more profound than
his collaborations with guitar II it's
just more interesting to me I I don't
like the stuff that he does with guitar
II I don't have some sort of like
hermeneutic key to all all of that I
just know that I've read around in the
corpus and that's my preference um
[Music]
Kierkegaard Todorov Kierkegaard or
Nietzsche who did it better
depends on what it is I don't know what
you mean so I can't answer that
van pearcy how do you find a good
philosophical problem to study and write
about is it just a vibe one gets or does
one maybe join the problems of the
projects of one's favorite philosophers
you know I don't know I've always had
more
topics and and and problems to write and
and do other things about then I've had
time to do so I'm the kind of person who
often like hands off projects to other
people and says this would be a good
thing for you to study for example right
now
a guy who I'm good friends with at the
University of Oslo he and I have been
doing some work on great paper proposed
for the aristotelian conference here in
Milwaukee for the summer before it got
cancelled
and dealing with prior ASIS in Aristotle
Epictetus Alexander of Aphrodisias and
simply kiyose and that came out of stuff
that he was interested in stuff that I
was interested in but right now he and I
are actually working on the stoic
paradox is not just in Cicero but in
Seneca and epictetus and other other
authors as well including Plutarch who
thought the Stoics you know where we're
actually a bunch of people who are off
base right Plutarch is a middle
plainness and I don't know you I just
kind of see stuff and I'm like oh that
looks interesting let's let's do that so
I'm not I'm not a I don't really have a
good answer to that I guess you could
say it's like a vibe you get that the
vibe is this looks really interesting
let's let's explore that and I wish that
I had more time than I do because I
would like to you know explore
everything and I and I kind of you know
if there is an afterlife and if there is
a heaven to it I kind of think about
that as being like a place where instead
of you know it's great today I could see
gods you know essence in itself and the
eternal law and all that the way Thomas
talks well that's nice I would like to
be able to actually have the time to
read everybody and think about the stuff
that they have to say and maybe get to
talk with them like you know when
Socrates talks about in the apology I
have I have to go down to hell I'll get
to talk with all these people and ask
them did they really say this and do
this you know that's that's that's kind
of how I picture heaven it's sort of
like the opposite of what Jorge Jorge
says right I picture heaven as a lie
I do kind of picture it as a library but
also as a workhouse where you get to
chatter with all these people and and
you know develop more more stuff whereas
I think he would have just like to go to
the corner and read books all right
both uh how do I handle not working out
not too bad so far I've actually lost
weight
I was sick for for you know some of this
time in the quarantine so I wasn't in
shape to work out and I'm gonna start
working out pretty soon I've got some
dumbbells that I've carried with me from
from place to place since college we've
got this long staircase I've got
calisthenics I can do from my army days
so I'll be doing and my wife wants to do
yoga so well I'll be working out before
too long I've just been so busy
that I haven't had time to do anything
ah Paul when you come up against one
school of thought versus a school a
version school of thought B when people
are branding things in their own way I
see it there's a lack of or the
hijacking of a lingua franca in my mind
the consequence of this is the arts
around form don't progress understanding
of knowledge when I give that a minute
or so of comment I'm not really sure
what's what's being said there you're
you're going back to like the stuff
about nominalism maybe or so I don't
really have much to say their
intellectual jujitsu what do you think
about the blueprint for totalitarianism
critique of Plato's Republic by people
like Russell and popper I think it's
utter garbage and they state they should
know better but they allowed their own
you know like I don't know what what
motivation it was some some sort of
emotional drive to allow them to cloud
their judgment and miss read the text
because you know Socrates doesn't say I
mean to begin with it's not even the
best ideal Society in book two it's the
second best right it's it's already the
luxurious City and Socrates tells you
why he sketches it out the way he does I
didn't think bad reading is so bad that
you're like what's going on here you
know you're smart
person why would you be saying these
things so that's that's what I have to
say all right the stoic teacher asks how
should we feel about the fact that much
of the modern self-help genre seems to
take wholesale from stoic philosophy
without referencing their sources well I
don't think that's the case I asked that
there's not a way in which much of the
modern spell
odds with the stoic philosophy and
that's part of what's what's wrong with
some of it you know the whole notion
that we should be like you know tryin
you think about the positive psychology
stuff which is some of that's even kind
of rigorous although a lot of it depends
on some pretty sketchy methodological
stuff you know a lot of self reporting
things this notion that we we ought you
know we ought to like have you know
preponderance of good emotions over bad
emotions well you know sometimes certain
emotions may serve a role that the key
is not to like just try to like have
more of this and less of that it's to
actually understand ourselves and to
figure out why we feel bad when we feel
bad and whether it serves any purpose or
whether we want to wean ourselves away
from it because we're making that
assumptions or doing things that are
damaging to ourselves I think a lot of
self-help stuff isn't really using much
from from stoicism I think a lot of it's
just kind of you know weak garbage quite
frankly so alright now I show are there
notable modern philosophers from the
east yeah there's lots of them I'm not a
specialist in that sort of thing but I
mean think about like there's whole
schools like the Kyoto School in Japan
again stuff I wish I had the time to
actually spend time to read because the
stuff that I am looks very very
interesting but I just don't have it all
right Sean Kelly with the online pivot
I'm finding resistance to media
pluralism and classes what are your
thoughts on curating and annotating
other lectures for your students I think
it's enough for me just to produce the
lectures that I do for my students I
don't actually have the time to go
through and ant you know curate and
annotate other people's lectures for the
most part but and I don't know what
media pluralism means that that's a term
that is probably from in my
communication studies I'd
I don't really know what it what it
means but you know if other people want
to curate and annotate other people's
lectures I think that's great
you know I'm more of a producer than a a
cataloger or curator let's you know it's
the way it works I only got 24 hours in
a day so oh right
Abdul will the current move there's a
really good question well the current
move to online school and work have long
lasting effects or well things go back
to normal a year from now so that's a
really good question early on and this
this shifted forget about education just
think about distance working there were
all these people who pointed out and I
saw this happening on Twitter and I'm
sure it happened on other social media
they are like you know my boss has been
I've been asking my boss to work from
home remotely and they said we can't
accommodate you and now suddenly
everybody's you know worried about kovat
and now everybody can work from home
right so this was all [ __ ] all along
we could have been doing it they could
have accommodated me or my spouse or you
know my brother or sister whoever is
under consideration now that we've done
it the cats out of the bag I think a lot
of people are gonna be reluctant to go
back to their workplaces they're gonna
be like well how do I know this is
actually like safe and clean you know
why can't we do things from home I think
that is gonna be a game changer in a lot
of places there there are some things
that you can't do remotely like say
stocking grocery shelves but or you know
like working in restaurants too but
there's a lot of stuff that actually can
be done remotely when it comes to
education I really depends you know
places that have built their reputation
on the you know intimacy of the small
classroom and stuff like that they are
really eager to get that group has that
as one of their selling points on the
sly they've already said listen we're
gonna expand your class
is from like 19 to 24 so there goes that
right I think there's a lot of there's
gonna be a lot of interesting things
that come out of this there was another
great Twitter conversation where
somebody was like you know
administrators should be figuring out
how to actually take these teachers who
got like you know a base cool and then I
wrote you know they probably want to tap
those of us who've been teaching online
for a long time and helped others
transition and you know identify those
those those people and have us be like
you know mentors or coaches that might
happen as well we don't know you know in
it here's the thing here in the United
States we don't have an educational
system we have this incredible big
patchwork of all these different
institutions and each one is like its
own little domain you know run by by the
people who are in charge of it and what
this college does down the street may
not be remotely like what this college
over here does so I think we're gonna
see a lot of different adaptations
happen all right
to do to do dododo to do just jumped a
little bit let me see it we've got here
and let me clean this up a little bit we
got some people who are just like
posting stuff over and over again
alright a lot of questions here here's
one from
Biswas is there any continental
philosopher incorporates mathematics and
logic into their work yeah although a
lot of times the use of mathematics and
logic is not what we would call very
rigorous think about like I write and
his graphs they didn't do any good as
far as I'm concerned I think they just
confuse things but you know you do have
other people who use you some things
some of them are people who are trying
to bridge the gap between analytic and
Continental guys says have you ready
Antonio Gramsci got Gramsci yeah I've
read a red gram she intellectual jujitsu
any thoughts on Schopenhauer's critique
of contours philosophy philosophy more
generally I like Schopenhauer I don't
really buy much of what he has to say
but I really enjoy reading him
stylistically and I you know I think
Schopenhauer less critique Conte and
more thought well you gotta take Conte
much much further
Uriah Mark Toner off why is whitehead so
underrepresented in philosophy well I
would say it's probably because process
and reality is so difficult I mean it's
like Hegel phenomenology or Hegel
science of logic difficult so when
you've got that level of difficulty it
drives a lot of people off and process
philosophy you know it's it's it's a
really small tradition these days all
right Sean Park I'm trying to start
Hegel's philosophy of history lectures
any secondary literature you'd recommend
or general advice on reading them I'm
not a secondary Lit guy you know again
it's a matter of time I spend my time
mostly reading primary texts and I'll
just say this the lectures on the
history of philosophy are easier than
the phenomenology so there's that going
for it the general advice I would say is
you're getting Hegel's take on stuff
you're not necessarily getting precisely
what Plato thought or the epic
Kurian slot or stuff like that game
Gabrielle what do you think about NHS
human all too human great book a Numis
do you speak Greek or Latin no I read
Greek and Latin right these are
classical languages nobody nobody really
speaks Greek or Latin there's not
there's not a point to doing that all
right I'm gonna have to wrap up in a
little bit so I'm going to skip down a
bit and see if like that do you could do
a lot of kind of goofy questions in here
alright let's scroll down here Cory has
a question about combining things is it
feasible to combine philosophical
systems such as stoicism and the Noble
Eightfold Path
well the Noble Eightfold Path is not a
philosophical system it's a part of it
alright and Buddhism is a is a vast set
of traditions you know so vast that
nobody is actually mastered all of that
that literature and can you combine you
know things like that can you combine
stoicism and Buddhism of some particular
variety yeah I mean you you can you can
always find like similarities but you
will also find places where you're like
you have to pick this or pick this like
you know for example the Buddhists there
were a few people called that we term
the personalist but they they more or
less died out but they were involved in
early discussions the the Buddhists idea
is that there's no self ultimately
there's all these phenomena that are
connected together in interesting
tangled ways but there isn't any self
and the Stoics say there is a self and
like epic tina's locates it basically as
the pro a racist which is the same thing
as the rational faculty or the ruling
faculty the hegemony comb right so you
got to pick one side or the other and
and you're not I mean you can try to
find some way to synchronize them but
you're gonna find things like that and
you can you can say that about any
attempt to combine philosophies you know
people are like wow I'm gonna mix
together stoicism and and Randy and
objectivism well that's a much harder
cell that's really you're not gonna work
well there's many more incompatible
elements so all right philosophy and
critical thinking what are your thoughts
on Bernard Williams ante theory
specifically as criticisms and morality
of the peculiar institution III don't
know
you're asking me about
thing that I haven't looked at for a
very long time never been a big fan of
Bernard Williams but yeah so I'm sorry
but I don't actually have a good answer
for you on that
let's see if we got something nice to go
out on here to do to do a lot of back
and forth discussions here okay here's a
good one
this is by Anubis top five philosophy
books everyone should read so you know I
think everybody ought to get and then
I'm gonna cheat a little bit you know
there's there's that that for dialogue
set called the last days of Socrates
that's got the Euthyphro apology credo
and Fredo in it but you know these are
platonic dialogues that's probably a
good one to read Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics what else is really really you
know I Louise's consolation of
philosophy is a really good one there's
a lot of things packed in there this is
gonna seem like an off-the-wall one but
Cicero's ami ends the whole thing all
the five books of it you're getting a
real great discussion of Epicureanism
what's great about it what's wrong with
that stoicism what's great about it
what's wrong with it and then some
platonic and Aristotelian philosophy and
then for the fifth I'm gonna say
something by Nietzsche and I don't know
maybe you know should be yon good and
evil or the genealogy of morals let's
say Beyond Good and Evil
you know because because it's
interesting it's aphoristic and in some
parts there's a lot of cool things going
on
err so that will be the the sign-off and
thanks for everybody for joining in on
this again you know topic was continuing
education in this time of COBIT with the
pivot online we covered a lot of other
ground but it's good that we did get to
talk about education which is something
that is really in transformation right
now right there's a lot of interesting
things going on so all right I'm gonna
sign off and say thanks to everybody for
joining me and well you know we do a
couple of these sometimes each month
when I have the time so I'm trying to
have the time these days and that's it